hello everyone welcome to cloud on air
live webinars from Google cloud we are
hosting webinars every Tuesday
my name is Antonio Chakraborty I'm the
product manager for clarity core and we
also have hi my name is Tom rubber Arya
I'm a technical program manager at
Google cloud focusing on IOT core and
what's around I will be talking about
Google Cloud IOT solution and cloud IT
core you can ask any questions any time
on the platform and we have Googlers on
standby to answer them so let's get
started as a starting point we need to
clarify what we mean by IOT the term is
overloaded as you know but let's stop
and think about it a bit imagine a city
with no congestion at all can i all t do
that imagine an airport with no delays
would I to be able to play a role in
that as well
imagine the perfect energy consumption
every day and every place how would I ot
make that happen as in healthcare as
well can you imagine that imagine
medicine that would be tailored with
each person again can i OT help with
that as well like like we see with games
but now with physical toys these are the
cues for IOT connecting the physical
world to the cloud and being able to get
a comprehensive view of an ecosystem
embedded with those fantastic outcomes
IOT is overrated yes but the reality is
that IOT is everywhere and is the key to
better outcome for everyone now it is
estimated that 8.4 billion devices are
connected just in 2017 which is more
than 30% higher in as compared to
previous year we are in a fast
accelerating part of an exponential
curve a single jet engine firm from GE
generates about 500 gigabytes of data
per floor
two jet engines per plane miss - one
terabyte of data how many flights per
day you you see where I'm going with
this right with Pratt & Whitney's geared
turbofan fitted with five thousand
sensors generate up to 10 gigabyte of
data per second a single a single you
know a single twin-engine aircraft with
average twelve hour flight time can
produce up to 844 data about a terabyte
of data to put it into perspective it
was estimated that Facebook accumulated
around 600 terabyte of data every day
into T in 2014 but with more than 700
engines pratt and 7,000 engines pratt &
whitney a Pratt Pratt could potentially
download zettabytes of data once all the
engines are in the field devices are
much faster and are constantly
generating a large amount of data and
we're at a time where we are generating
more data than ever before and not only
our devices being connected and
generating extremely large volume of
data it is happening virtually in every
industry if we look at manufacturing or
industrial we sink impact to every
aspect of business from connected
devices on the shop floor to connected
products in the field from a paper
machine you know that one you know the
one which makes diapers for example
generates about 4 terabyte of data per
machine annually or perhaps a gas or a
stream turbine generates a ton of data
annually as well we you know in fact we
have partners who are already delivering
solutions for in for manufacturing or
built on Google cloud platform which
we'll talk about as well we have also
seen IOT solutions in healthcare whether
it is personalized medicine or asset
tracking send asset tracking in hospital
someone like a company called Dexcom
which which continuously monitors
glucose today and are sending 10k
compressed hourly post expected which is
expected to grow to about one terabyte
of data per month
this is compressed size the extracted
data will likely be 10x
what it sends from the glucose monitor
if you look at transportation industry
for example we're seeing significant
changes there as well
we're seeing applications in commercial
vehicles to vehicles on the supplies for
example we sing the use of telematics to
improve customer service by responding
to early signs of failure in commercial
vehicles and avoiding unexpected
breakdowns and towing this use of
telematics and maps are again generating
a ton of data which can be then
processed to get meaningful insights
from the field if you look at consumer
products industries we're seeing a
number of use cases there as well for
market personalization for marketing
personalization but recently we want to
deal with a large toy manufacturer for
focused on reinventing their business
during driving innovation and disruption
so you get the point so you know when
you think about these large volume
billions of devices connecting to cloud
or through the internet it results in
generating a massive amount of data from
all these devices which are much larger
than what humans have been generating so
far so this is IOT data and Google has
been dealing with this kind of data for
a long time in fact Google is one of
those companies which has seven products
we generate which which has more than 1
billion 30-day active consume active
users and all these devices and users
are generating a ton of data in in
petabytes exabytes every day and what
happens to what happens when you collect
that's a massive scale of data
well you become a master of big data and
you become a data-driven company this is
our strength this is what Google brings
to customer that nobody else can
mastering big data has some benefits
you know we can here we can use the data
to get clean key key insights we can
build machine learning models and so on
and so forth if you if allows you to
supercharge innovation and bring new
answers to hard problems we've been
working on this for a decade and we have
used our knowledge to help our
enterprise our customers and developers
in in solving these big data and
in learning problems when collected this
massive scale of data we have worked an
energy sector with our data center
optimization we've also worked with in
many other fields as well when were you
talking about IOT we don't just focus on
one iota product or a couple of fiber
product we really want to drive the
conversation toward business outcome
enabled by Google Cloud IOT analyzing
big data in-stream or batch and then
applying machine learning capabilities
it is together clarity as a solution and
under the clarity umbrella the customers
will be supercharged so what does it
mean when we think when we say cloud IOT
solution well as we started talking to
our customers and partners and
developers there were three challenges
which which which appeared and Google as
Google as a company we've been dealing
with this challenges for a long time
first is securely connecting things
right securely apply to device
connectivity and connect and
communication and identity nobody wants
their devices to be hacked and you've
heard cases in the past where this has
happened and you know of the
consequences so how do you make sure
that all these devices you know hundreds
of thousands of millions and billions of
devices which are on the field are has
the right security patches has the right
version of its firmware and and it's
very it's very unlikely to be hacked and
compromised and how do you make sure
that all these devices can securely
connect to to go to Google cloud or to
other cloud platform second is scale
we're talking about unprecedented data
as I just mentioned you know engines G
engines generate gigabytes of data per
day and so when you think about that
level of scale how do you make sure that
you can ingest the data at scale from
millions of billions of these connected
devices and you can store all this data
in a cost-effective way and you can act
analyze and process it in a in a
meaningful way as well and third is
actionable insights once you have this
data
what do you do with it and end of the
day why does a customer need IT if it
cannot get any meaningful insights and
this is again where we have been working
with our consumer products and number of
products to to understand to analyze
data to get really meaningful insights
which we think we can share with the
audience at large so as I mentioned we
know women working for a decade on
large-scale interest infrastructure and
machine learning and we've built our IOT
stack on the same technology that we the
and tools that we use at Google for
Google search for this two billion
Android devices that connect to Google
every day and we what we we have an
end-to-end solution to derive
intelligence in the moment with Google
karate here is an example here is an
architecture of devices that can connect
a Google cloud via cloud IOT core which
is a new service which I will just which
I'll mention about and you can use our
downstream services such as pop sub
cloud function dataflow cloud bigquery
machine learning and other services for
storage processing analysis and using
machine learning for predictive insights
as well the great thing about this are
Google cloud IT solution is that you can
seamlessly move IOT data across Google
services and you can decide which
services suits you best for your
business use case and then use it for
specific use cases you can for ingest
data with chlorotic or you can
distribute data with cloud pub/sub apply
data transformation with cloud dataflow
and then store data using with cloud
bakery or big cloud storage or BigTable
you can perform ad hoc analysis with
Google Cloud Google big bigquery
visualized data using cloud data studio
or data lab and then derive intelligence
using cloud machine learning
so let's start with article what is
clarity core so cloud article is a new
service which we announced last year and
we just announced a general availability
of this service it's a fully managed
service that allows you to easily and
securely connect your iOS devices to
Google cloud and then manage and ingest
data from millions of global
and we think you would benefit from this
service as well so a couple of key
benefits of clarity core as you know
Google is Google is the probably the
only non isp company who has fiber-optic
deployment across Atlantic in a cross
Pacific Pacific Ocean and we have a
number of point of presence throughout
throughout the globe what allows what
this allows us to do is to is to provide
a single global endpoint for your
devices to connect to quadratic or
whether your devices or your vehicle or
your acid is in u.s. or somewhere in
Asia or some in Africa you just connect
your device to Google Cloud IT core and
leveraging our global networking
infrastructure we will connect it to the
closest point of presence and from there
we'll connect it to our closest data
center so you don't have to worry about
picking which particular server you need
to connect to you just connect to one
globulin point for Google cloud article
and we take care from their clarity core
has two key components one is what we
call it as a protocol bridge and second
is the device manager what's great about
protocol bridge is we realize that most
of the industrial devices are using
standard protocols such as MQTT and even
su DT in many cases so with cloud
radical we have native support for MQTT
3.1 and above and what's great about
this is you you can connect your devices
without worrying about instantiating
resource or infrastructure or a VM you
just whether you're connecting one
device or you connecting 10,000 or you
connect or you connecting millions of
devices as you get ready for deployment
you just connect a device over Mt DT or
HTTP and we internally scale for you so
we have automatic load balancing built
in as part of chlorotic or managed
service and it's in sclerotic or it
connects with publishes its data to
pop sub you get a global you can have
global data you can remotely access all
your device data from a central location
and you can monitor all your devices or
your factories from a central location
that way the second component of Florida
Cory's device manager and this is where
we allow users and developers to
remotely manage control and monitor
their devices so we first of all we
really care about security and so we
have the provision to individually
authenticate each i/o t devices we
support a symmetric key based
authentication where the public key is
is stored in with Florida core and the
private key is stored with with the
device and we use the standard Joe token
for assigning the assigning to sign with
the private key and that's what we use
for individually authentication
authenticating each device you can use
our device manager on chlorotic or to
update configuration of the devices and
even control the devices you can for
example send firmware updates or new
configuration or new setting remotely
from the coil to device your application
just needs to call an API and quadratic
or make sure that those new settings
gets propagated to all the devices as
they come online we also have added row
level access to two to two different
groups of devices so for example you
might want to give only grant only view
level access to certain groups of users
or you might want to have ad grind to
just add or delete level access so their
their variety of variety of role levels
rules which you can grant by using clora
I'm on Google Cloud writing code and you
might have heard this term digital twin
in and this is something which is used a
lot in the industry with clarity core
essentially offers you digital twin
which is a logical representation of
your device on on on the Google cloud
we also have a rich set of api's and a
UI console for device deployment and
monitoring as well so we have this is
this is a fully again is a fully managed
service with a rich set of api's which
allows you to securely connect manage
and ingest data at scale from your iot
devices recently we added a new set of
features as well with our recent beta
and J release you can bring your own
certificate for for regional security
you know users can now bring their own
device key which are signed by the
certificate authority for for device
authentication logical device a
presentation I just talked about which
is essentially a digital twin on Google
Cloud ID Kol and we've also added
support for HTTP in addition to M PTT as
well now we understand that many of you
whether you're with a developer or a
device partner or a customer before you
go full scale deployment you would want
to build some prototypes and proof of
concept to to play with to understand
the are why and to really understand the
impact priority so in our case we have a
simple UI user interface for management
of devices monitoring these devices as
well so here's an example of is a
screenshot of our Google Cloud console
where if you scroll down on the Left
menu and you can go to IOT core and you
can start you can start sort of adding
your devices and then monitoring them as
well so it's a very simple UI which can
really get you started with IOT core we
have a notion of registry which
essentially is a collection of devices
and and and within a specific region so
you can you can start by creating a
device registry and then the next step
once you create a device registry for
example here we have created a registry
called weather station once you've
created a registry you can add a devices
to it and as you add devices you would
specify the public key for authentic
and there a bunch of other settings
which you can add to it as well once
once you've added and registered a
device when the physical device connects
to Google already core you would be able
to see the status of of those devices on
the same user UI console and with this
UI console you're also able to not just
monitor the incoming data but you're
also able to send configuration or or
updates to the device from the UI as
well so we made sure that we not only
can handle the massive scale but we also
have a simple UI for you to get started
quickly for your initial proof of
concept or concept or prototypes so once
you've used a quadratic or for ingesting
for connecting your devices in a secure
way and then you manage them at scale
remotely you can use pops up for
ingestion and distribution of data the
great thing about pop sub is that it has
durable message persistence which means
pops up stores the data which is which
is published to it for for seven days so
what happens here is IOT core as the
devices connect to already core and has
they published data as they start
transmitting data highly code then
publishes data from all these devices in
a registry to one pop subtopic and that
pops up topic that pops up and keeps the
data for seven days so even if you lose
some if you lose some connectivity you
still have persistence on the data and
as pops up is a global service you can
use pops up to remotely monitor to do
monitor to have a central monitoring
system for all your globally disposed
devices in addition pops up is can be is
a great tool for distribution
distributing data to other downstream
services such as cloud function data
flow or even you know your own ETL
pipeline so if you have a simple you can
build a simple business logic for
example the second example if you just
want to meet a monitor the incoming
temperature data from your temperature
sensor and say
every time if it goes above 80 degree
Fahrenheit you want to turn on a fan
what you can do here is you can write a
simple Claud function which which
subscribes to pops up and as it collects
as it gets that temperature readings
from the devices connected to flour
attic or your your logic will kick in
and then you can send a command back to
particle to turn on the fan
data flow can be used for more complex
event processing say similar to how you
scroll function and here you can have a
window and you can say you know I want
to compute the median temperature over a
10 SEC 10 minute window or a 10 second
window this is great for a a complex
data a complex data plus processing as
well and what pops up allows you to do
is it allows you to abstract your and
separate your upstream devices from a
downstream application so you can
continue to make changes on your
downstream application without meaning
to update the library or the form where
of your of your devices so Clara I decor
in conjunction with pub/sub provides you
a great set of services for securing
your securely connecting your devices at
scale have ingesting data at scale and
then distributing this data to
downstream services for storage
processing and analysis so that was
cloud ID code and how you can build a
solution with Google Cloud variety now
I'm going to hand it off to Sam Wright
who's gonna give you a demo Thank You
Denis so for this demo which we are
about to show you simulate an attic
racking company which can have multiple
devices or sensors around the globe
let's go back quickly
so we wanted to showcase how we can
build an end-to-end application using
Google Cloud IOT core and other Google
cloud services like dataflow bigquery
App Engine and visualize data on a
dashboard in real time I wanted to
quickly go over how the backend is set
up article is designed specifically to
securely connect manage and ingest data
from globally dispersed devices we have
set up up subtopics and device
registries to connect the devices once
connected they send the telemetry data
wire MQTT to IOT core endpoint as raw
data is arriving into pop subtopics we
then use their flow which is which
subscribes to pop subtopics set up
earlier cow data flow is a fully managed
service for transforming and enriching
data streaming in this could be
real-time or batch data the data for
pipeline then dumps the data into
bigquery which is our data warehouse
bigquery also other scales and setup is
easy all we need to do is specify a data
schema to get started so from there we
also have some cloud function setup
which also check value of the data
against cloud sequel if a certain
threshold is crossed we can then Craig a
cloud function routine based on alert
require current threshold setups are
defined for weather temperature and G
events we're also using cloud datastore
to store geofencing data and in the end
we are tying all of this information
using App Engine in particular App
Engine flags and we also using Google
Maps API to visualize the data points on
a dashboard we are also calling some
shipping API which knows shipping routes
of a certain certain ship or certain
ship might take now switching over to
the demo
so as you can see here we have built a
dashboard where we can see all devices
and sensors a typical atha tracking
company might have we have the following
items on screen we have ships which are
transferring goods from around the globe
and then we have large containers which
are carrying our goods from dock yards
into warehouses and then we have trucks
out here which are delivery trucks which
are transferring data from the
warehouses to a customer or to a to a
certain asset on the ground one thing to
note here is no matter where the device
is are located in the world you need to
change you need not to change which end
point the data is sent to so you can
have devices and you cannot divide it in
the US or in Australia or even in China
you are the developer do not need to
specify an end point where the data has
to go Google front-end will take care of
routing the packet to the closest
location let's drill down a little bit
deeper on what kind of information these
devices are sending us so in this case
we have a ship
and this ship will have a bunch of
sensors on them and if you can see this
is the passenger fleet out there out
here we have a passenger fleet ship out
here and we're calling shipping API is
to see what is the flag of the ship and
then we have a bunch of sensors on the
date on this ship itself which is
streaming data using IOT core we can see
temperature readings we can see
temperature readings we can see course
the ship is taking as well as the wind
speed the ship is encountering all this
information is being streamed through
IOT core in real time and we can
visualize this information on on a
dashboard running on App Engine let's
let's take another example here of a
truck which is enroute or which is in
delivery route to a customer so for this
truck again we have a bunch of sensors
on this truck as its traveling from
point A to point B we want to track what
are the equipment status if it's fall or
I have data being unloaded we want to
make sure what are the door styles we
are this is for security purposes
to see if someone opened the cargo door
during transit we also have ambient
temperature within the cargo hold and we
also have some device battery the device
battery levels for each devices on board
as the as the truck is making its
journey across from point A to point B
it's streaming gear to us real-time and
we can visualize this on screen we can
also interact with the devices on these
trucks for example we want to set
threshold or what is the perfect
temperature the cargo hold should have
so let's say in this case let's take a
little extreme let's take it we wanted
to one degree Celsius once you said that
the device the RIT core communicates
back to the device and tell that this is
the new threshold it needs to act
against we also use cloud function in
the backend to trigger if certain
threshold across so if you can see on
screen as the threshold is being crossed
we is having alerts generated on screen
you can also see the history of all the
data that this device has been streaming
all this information is stolen to
bigquery we are we are passing the data
from the device to IOT core to do data
flow and then to bigquery and then we're
querying it using App Engine of
application you can also interact with
other API is like Google Maps API and
then make this hole into an application
work let's take an example out here we
were where we want to set up a geofence
and if a device crosses the geofence we
want some kind of an alert
okay yeah as you see if the device and
if the device is not in a particular
geofence we are having the notification
on screen so we wanted to show the
robustness of IIT code and how it
interacts with various of the subsystems
underneath and how fast this whole
application works you can also see
historically alert that IIT cover has
been generated the devices have been
generating and sending it to IOT core so
like in the real estate earlier it
doesn't matter if you have few hundred
devices or thousands of devices on
million devices we scale automatically
for you
you can seamlessly interact with other
Google products like Google Maps API and
datastore based on data streaming into
IOT core hopefully the small demo was
able to demonstrate the robustness or
IOT core and how you can use it for your
own business logic or for your own
personal projects thank you for your
time and over to you in the nail
thank you Sam Rock let's go back to the
slides
so as some rod gave you a demo of asset
tracking and what was great in this demo
was you could see real-time the movement
of the asset you know and and it's
whether it's in US and different
location we can still provide same
real-time tracking across a crowd
regardless of the location and it uses
IOT core geo Google geo api's and bunch
of other services to really where all of
this comes together for a complete
solution so the the point I want to make
here is you know we Google cloud ID is
really a platform for end-to-end IOT
data processing so we have four four
four injections connection and
management of your IOT device data we
have high tech old cloud pub/sub we also
have Android things which I'm going to
talk about in a bit for processing and
cleaning and storing in a cost-effective
way for this massive amount of data we
have dataflow function a cloud functions
BigTable spanner and even GCS and
finally to analyze it visualize and then
predict outcomes with bigquery clock
data lab machine learning engine data
studio and you can even even use cloud
functions and and data flow so Google
cloud really has an int and all the set
of services which you need to build an
end-to-end solution and build some
compelling application just the way some
are just showed you about real time
asset tracking I want to touch upon
Android things which is our version of
an operating system for the IOT devices
Android thing essentially is Android
variety and what's great about Android
things is it gives you three key the
three key benefits one is since it's
built on Android it's highly security so
secure is a secure boot operating system
and if you have a gateway or a device
which runs Android things it's very very
hard for that device to be compromised
second is its managed fully managed by
Google you know when you have
millions of billions of Ohio T devices
globally dispersed you want to make sure
that all those devices has the right
form reversion has the right security
patches and has the same version across
all the devices just the way we do it
with our Android mobile phones and and
Chromebooks Android things also makes
ensures that all your fleet of devices
will have the same operation of
operating system and security patches as
well so that's that's great for for for
a large enterprise and even a
medium-sized enterprise customer and
finally Android things comes with it
comes with support for some of our guru
services such as change the flow and
machine learning so you can imagine if
you have a camera which runs Android
things where you and you have a cloud
machine learning model or a tensorflow
model to to detect your faith at faces
of employees coming employees of your
company the action the training of the
model can happen in cloud the inference
can still happen locally on the camera
using Android things and it's set of
api's so it's it really makes it easy
for you to build compelling applications
and the ground on the benefit of Android
things related benefit is since its
Android you who are you're tapping into
the Android Android application
developer ecosystem as well so it's
really easy to build edge compare
applications for for each computer as
well so with Android things it's secure
manageability is secure boot and API is
- for for machine learning and it works
and it works seamlessly with Google RIT
core we we believe we have a pretty
compelling solution for not just on the
cloud aspect but also in the device
aspect so you can build an end-to-end
solution for your business specific use
cases we also we're women we understand
that in for in order for our platform to
be to be to be more self useful
we can't just do everything on our own
so we have we've been working hard to
build our partner ecosystem both on the
device side as well as on the
application side so we have a number of
device partners such as Intel CR
Wireless and XP arm Marvell a bunch of a
large number of device partners who have
IOT devices which works seamlessly with
Google Cloud IT course if you if you're
using any of our partner devices you
know it'll work seamlessly with Google
alrighty core we also have a number of
essays and and application partners in
the as part of the ecosystem who can
help you build your specific application
for for your I to use cases come
companies such as new beau Augusto
Lawson so take all this guy all these
partners can help you build specific IOT
application using Google cloud platform
and quality core so we're very very
excited about our growing part of the
ecosystem and this is just a snapshot we
have a lot and a lot more on the website
as well so why clarity and you know I
think I just want to summarize the
reason why we think you as a developer
as a partner or as a customer should use
Google RIT for your IP application one
cloud radical lets developers and
enterprise easily connect your millions
of devices which are globally dispersed
through the protocol endpoint again it's
a global endpoint which less hassle and
less require and no worries about scale
we take care of automatic scaling and
that's great for application and
developers so that you can focus on your
business application and not worry about
the underlying infrastructure second is
as part of Google cloud IT platform you
you not just connect collecting your
device data but connecting your global
device network on intelligent cloud
Google cloud machine learning and Big
Data in innovations make Heidi day
makes who helps you to make sense of the
IOT data you know you can perform a lark
analysis as I mentioned with bigquery
you can visualize data with doing a data
studio and you can derive meaningful
intelligent insights using cloud machine
learning and third is your caller ID
code is a server T is built in the
service architecture it's a fully
managed service so you don't have to
instantiate a separate instance of
chlorotic or you just connect your
devices to clarity core and off you go
with your application so whether you're
connecting really yours you start with
few devices as you embark on your
journey with the proof-of-concept to
when you're ready for deployment has
when you and your you want to deploy
millions or hundreds of thousands or
billions of devices it's a it's the same
application which you would just use the
same service that you just connected
without worrying about the underlying
infrastructure
Forte's given our global network we can
really offer minimal latency and it's
particularly for I in case of IOT every
in millisecond every second matters and
latency is critical and Google ensures
that your devices is delivered with the
lowest latency using our global
networking infrastructure the highest
quality of private network connects that
connects our regional locations and data
centers to more than 100 global network
points of presence close to your device
handy users this means that devices the
device will always connect to the
closest point of presence and benefit
from our networking global network
backbone with lowest latency and finally
chlorotic all works seamlessly with
millions of Android things devices and
devices from leading hardware makers
manufacturers such as Intel nxp
microchip Marvell Sierra was and and
others and Android things device
operating system is updated and passed
by Google as data is generated in the
sensor it seamlessly moves into Google
Cloud for processing analyzing and
integration so that was an overview and
a demo for peyote for building IQ
solution on on Google cloud thank you
for your time and stay tuned for live
Q&A we will be back in less than a
minute
you
thank you everyone for the questions
that we received from the audience I'm
gonna what we some other my gonna walk
you through and try a try to answer as
many as we can so let's just get started
so one other question was the first
question we had was what are some of the
advantages of MQTT over HTTP so there
are a couple of advantages first of all
what we find that in the industry many
of the devices are already using mqtt
and mkdd as you know is is relatively
it's a little bit new format which was
introduced in I think it's towards the
end of 1990s the key benefits are with
mqtt is built over TCP so you can use
TLS for and achieve the same level of
security as you do with HTTP in addition
with MPT T the payload size the
bandwidth consumption is much low I you
can hear the the you know you can send
binary data over a cm qgd and that saves
you a lot in bandwidth so that is one of
the key reason why many of these devices
use MPT T and you don't need much
storage space with a QT D so you can
have a smaller footprint for device
that's right you don't need much storage
space and then second is mkdd has this
topic structure which which really works
well for devices for in as devices
publish data on a particular topic and
you have applications subscribing to
those topics to collect data and you can
also use it for device to device
communication as well so those are the
two key benefits for of MQTT over HTTP
second question what formats are
supported for payload so we have you
know the way we we look at IOT core is
we've taken a set of a data agnostic and
a format agnostic approach at the same
time our recommendation is you can use
JSON as a format you can you can also
use protobuf if you if if bandwidth is
as critical for you anyone you want to
save every bit you can use protobuf as
well to send binary data third questions
do I have to create keys for devices on
the cloud you take that yeah we are well
can use key or you can also use
certificate so we have your bring your
own certificate mechana zone where you
can generate your own certificate give
us the public eye certificate on IOT
core and you can have your devices sign
with your private certificate so you can
choose whatever part you want to take
you can create your keys on on flower
idak or you can do it using open ssl on
your machine or you can get your own
certificates yeah and I think yeah you
know this is if I understand it right
you really want to create virtual
devices on cloud 4 for the purpose of
testing and the short answer is yes even
even if you're creating virtual devices
to connect to cloud decor you have to
use private keys and public keys private
public key combination to connect a
quadratic or otherwise it could reject
connection and and then on our website
there are very clear instruction and
sample which will help you to create
generate keys if whether it's for
virtual device or even for physical
device then the final question is how
can I use multiple MQTT topics so there
are the two ways to address this
question one is if we if you're trying
to connect if you trying to use multiple
topics on the device side today we said
we have we support two parent level
topic right so one for sending telemetry
which is events telemetry events and one
for for the device to publish its own
state information and four for telemetry
we all the default device the topic is
slashed vents devices class device
address events when you can create
subfolders so if you want to extend
temperature as a separate on a separate
topic you can say slash event slash
temperature or slash event slash
pressure and interesting enough this
just now energy release we also had and
you have a new feature which will allow
you to map these different MQTT topics
to a different pop subtopic or on Google
cloud so you can map the temperature
topic to temperature pops up to pop
certain for the topic and then so on and
so forth so you can really use multiple
topics both on device side as well as on
the clock side great so thanks everyone
again for the time and hopefully this
was useful and we would love to hear
your feedback stay tuned for the next
session end-to-end machine learning with
tensorflow on Google cloud platform live
from our Kirkland office and thanks
again thank you everyone
you